there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock right here we are back again
with a episode 142 ted serios and
thoughtography yes yeah
this was actually since we had done true
crime topics for the last two weeks we
did Madeleine McCann and we did serial
killer Robert Pickton I think before the
week before that so I figured okay well
now it's time to do a paranormal or
historical mystery type of thing so I
was asking Tom for ideas and he came up
with this particular epic yeah what
story behind this one is those of you
who are not regular listeners when I was
13 I had this poltergeist event in my
family and Jenny bought a book about it
anyway later on I ended up seeing this
documentary about this guy who was
taking cameras and put him up to his
head and clicking hitting the trigger to
take a photograph gonna be good he would
go oh I think I got that I think I got
something on that one or that one didn't
do it and then later they would develop
the film and it was mostly just pictures
of him looking into the cameras or all
white ones or all black ones but every
now and then there'd be a mysterious
photograph or an image on that film and
it was never really explained how he
could do it some people thought was some
kind of trick but he said he was putting
his thoughts or his psychic images onto
this film and he has psychiatrist that
was kind of believing in it and with it
and was taking him on tour
yeah and they couldn't really debunk the
guy I've seen the photographs there
they're weird photographs but I wanted
Jenny to try to get down to the bottom
of it as she could and to see what she
you know came up with cuz it seemed
plausible to me at the time and another
thing was weird is that I was thinking
well if it's fake then he would be able
to do it all the time but evidently
he can't do it most of the time you know
he's only done it a few times it's just
kind of kind of yeah I was a kid last
time I looked into it just at the time
it seemed like there might have been
something to it yeah I think the first
thing I heard about it because when when
we were trying to come up with a topic
for the show when we were talking to you
said you said let's do a show about that
guy that can put pictures on you know
film like just from his imagination yet
he did do Drock what's that that I was
like yeah maybe and I couldn't I
couldn't remember his name but then I
googled I'm like oh yeah that guy and
then like I found all the little video
clips and stuff and I remembered seeing
this on I think I saw it on arthur c
clarke
arthur c clarke world of mysterious
powers like from the late 60s early 70s
there was like a there was a show that
was i think it was about like just
spirit photography type things or
photographic anomalies or whatever and
then they had like a maybe five or six
minute segment about Todd dead serious
on that there was also a show and I
think it's on YouTube cuz I watched it
the other day it was like some big long
like hour and a half two hour long thing
with like Raymond Burr hosting and it
was just like about psychic phenomena in
general and that hat also had a section
on this type of you know thoughtography
as they call it and Ted series and they
kind of talked about that a little bit
on there I think I saw you that one of
those two there was like a part in that
there was a part in the program where he
walks by a video camera they had some
kind of a convention or he was maybe
just a kind of press release he walks by
a video camera and somebody goes Ted Ted
do the camera do the camera he goes up
to the news camera looks into it and
does something and then there was like a
just an image I think it was a like a
still image of a landscape or something
I remember exactly what it was I
remember seeing it as a kid and being
kind of mystified I don't know if it was
real though yeah you know but they were
looking for a they were trying to debunk
the god and catch him
playing some kind of house site
sleight-of-hand trick but they never
really could
as far as I far as I remember yeah why
you don't do there's more to it than
that the there there is more to why we
get the stuff out of the way yeah I just
had a couple of shout outs to do before
we kind of get into the topic at hand
and we actually have two new patrons
they've actually I think they came out a
couple weeks ago but we recorded some
ahead of time so I didn't get to like
announce them on the last show so we
have two new patrons named Damian and
Duane so hey you guys thank you very
much for your support thanks for joining
everything you guys do helps us out I've
also got like a lot of really nice like
email messages and stuff like that in
the past couple weeks about just people
talking about how they really appreciate
our show and yeah we're real grateful
especially in a time when basically new
members have stalled channel growth is
just like just stalled because and it's
not just us it's everybody YouTube has
changed algorithms and channels don't
grow like they used to we used to be
able to get Lena a hundred new subs of a
day sometimes you know but now not
anymore
it's a weird lucky to get like a couple
of week yeah so you know we're lucky I
guess
to have patrons well yeah yeah we're
definitely lucky that patrons and lucky
to have subscribers and if we were
starting out right now we would never
would get patrons at the rate that we're
doing yeah yeah because YouTube has
everybody kind of shadow band well like
I said I really appreciate all the
messages that I get from you guys and
you know we just we mostly just yeah we
have patreon and stuff what we mostly
just do this for fun cuz you know we
like to do it and we like interacting
with you guys and hopefully give you all
something fun to listen to while you're
doing whatever you do when you're
working or you just hanging out in your
house or whatever so that's really cool
and I really like getting all this
message so I just thought I would say
that yeah in case I didn't get back to
everybody individually although I do try
to do that eventually yes she's getting
busy she's writing books a new job stuff
she's doing writing articles for a
paranormal program it's a lot of stuff
going on
and honestly faceless villain 3 is
coming along quite well too I've just
I've just been working on the 1987
chapter today so this volume 3 is gonna
be from 1980 to 1999 by the end of the
year
yeah I'm shooting for August September
at the latest I mean it's on track right
now to be done by then it's selling to
part 1 & 2 sound well yeah yeah so I'm
kind of hoping once the trilogy is done
and like I said once the trilogy is done
I'm considering either starting another
trilogy about like creepy disappearances
or I might do a fourth unsolved murder
one that's like new millennium type
thing like from 2000 to 2019 you know
what I mean I mean because that would be
kind of in line with the rest of the
series yeah it is a 20 year period yeah
that's right so I don't know I'll just
I'll figure out what to do when when
volume 3 is done and I'll see what I
feel like when I get to the end of the
year and get that project out of the way
so let's talk a little bit about now the
the whole thing about photography um it
actually predates ted serios there were
other people claiming to be able to do
this like going back to like the
beginning of the 20th century and I
think that actually the term
thoughtography was sort of sort of
coined in Japan but I think we'll talk
about that like on the second half of
the show because we can kind of go into
like a few of the other people like
prior to ted serios that that claim to
be able to do this now this is not
spirit photography spirit photography is
kind of like your thing where you know
Victorian era when you know photography
was still kind of a new art form and you
would get these photos like people would
produce photos with like double
exposures and stuff like that that
looked like there was a ghost in there
like there's a very famous one with Mary
Todd Lincoln that looks like the you
know the assassinated Abe Lincoln is
like standing behind her with it yeah
yeah and they're they're not very good
fakes I mean they're pretty
good for the time because they didn't
have Photoshop back then you guys had to
do everything the hard way um but it's
interesting because a few years ago I
was in I guess I was in New York and it
was either at the Met or MoMA I can't
remember where I was but they actually
had an exhibition about all these kind
of like Victorian spirit photography and
seance photography and stuff like that
and it would kind of say how they did
them and all this other stuff but they
were so even though you know that
they're fake they're still really cool
to look at and like some of the images
are like really creepy and it's and it's
kind of cool to think of how you know
they did them before because now it's
like like I said it's like super easy to
do this I can do a picture like that in
[ __ ] five minutes in Photoshop as
most people probably could but the fact
that they had to go through so much work
to do them like back then and they some
of them actually were pretty cool
looking even though you could tell most
of them were yeah they were bilking
people out of money super fake yeah and
it's like I I wondered at the time we
were talking about this the other day I
said I wonder did people if you got
something like that produced it's like
did you know that that was fake or do
you just want to believe that that was
real it's like yeah I wanted to that was
my dead wife back there I think there
was it I think there was a certain kind
of novelty to it because how could you
believe that that was a photograph of
your dead husband when it's obviously a
reproduction of an old photograph that
you had already had
yeah because back then it's like getting
photographed was like a big deal and
there was only one or two pictures of
people superimposed there yes funny that
looks like the only photo that was ever
taken of dude while he was alive what it
is that you took your old photo to the
photographer and asked for that
yeah can you ghost this up ghosty man I
mean he's still with us
I think that's that's a lot of it look
like to me yeah I think it kind of
stemmed from the same of this is kind of
morbid too but I think it kind of
stemmed from the same mindset where
people would take pictures with their
dead babies or like their dead relatives
just because like I said photography was
it was a big deal so that was like the
only picture that you had yeah of that
person so it's like well I guess we'll
have to take it after they're dead since
we
you didn't get one when they were alive
so I think that was kind of like maybe
yeah there's a real creepy one of a
living girl she's alive about seven
laying down next to her dead brother
smile and that's what I mean and it's
like maybe it wasn't weird to them but
it's like hey little Suzy why don't you
go down lay next to little Bobby jr.
over there but yes so spirit photography
that's a totally different thing
photography doesn't really I mean yes
it's considered paranormal in the sense
that it's like the you know if it's real
it's thought to be caused by some it's
like psyche
psychokinesis like I can project my
thoughts like with energy or whatever
like onto film so it's paranormal in
that sense but it doesn't have anything
to do with like dead people coming back
to life or nothing like that
so it's more of psychokinetic why could
you do this well you know nikola tesla
in an offhand way sort of thought that
something like this might be possible
mm-hmm like he was kind of saying
something like he thought that it might
be possible to provide project your
thoughts onto like an outside retina
like a television yeah so I think
there's actually some new guys that
would kind of agree with him that there
may be a way to do that yeah cuz there
are some people that are I think
researching consciousness and they
thought that maybe you might even be
able to upload and download information
in and out of the human mind through the
eye yet I think that's kind of what
Tesla was getting at right so he did
really and I'm not saying I don't know
if it's possible or not but I mean he
did seem to think that that was
something that was within there
evidently they still think which I don't
know how that would work but there are
some people are saying no you could do
that which I - yeah - and they
supposedly would know maybe thought in
some weird way well maybe it's interact
some kind of electromagnetic inside this
back of the eye yeah well they did
videotape the vision what that cat saw
they tapped into a cat
I said you can look on it on YouTube
take it tap put some electrodes into a
cat's brain and then they hooked those
wires up to a computer and put that onto
a camera so you could see on a screen
now CB they put it onto a screen to a
monitor you could see through the cat's
eyes oh yeah what the cat was saying
what the cat was seeing it was kind of
fuzzy but then a person gets in front of
that cat and looks at it and you can see
the person looking at the cat but what
was weird is that when you looking at
the cats version of what you're seeing
you're not I mean you look at the screen
that person looks awful cat like the
eyes kind of look like cat eyes and
it'll look like that guy had big ol cat
ears on him it's the creepiest thing
it's there on YouTube I hope that's what
kitties really think because I would
love to think that baby cookie looks at
us and goes that's big mommy and daddy
kitty yeah yeah so - evidently you're
not it's not just exactly what the cat
sees it's what the cat perceives yeah so
it perceives a human being is just being
a big cat well your faces are all kind
of like cat faces I guess in some ways
cheers me yeah but you know that's why I
see that's why I don't think it's weird
that like we got ourselves like you know
her mom and dad because it's like
probably how she sees it okay she's just
like walking around I don't think I
think she just sees herself as a human
when she looks at it when she looks in
the mirror she sees herself with little
human ears I do feel like she ugly I
think she's more like I think she thinks
she's a tiny buddy fuzzy person rather
than seeing us as like she cats because
just the way she interacts and like lays
around she is she sleeps like a person
like your back like so oh yeah you gotta
get back - I definitely think she's on
it she's thinks she's a person all right
so let's talk about ted serios you know
he was originally from Chicago he had
been a bellhop at a hotel but he was
unemployed when his talents came to the
attention of the media or whatever
another first person that I'm not really
sure a lot of the you know a lot of the
biographical information about it
doesn't really say how him and this
psychiatrist got hooked up I don't know
if he was like if temptation on TV or if
he was but well I don't think so because
Ted was from Chicago and Julie's and bud
who was the psychiatrist he was from
Denver so I feel like I don't know if he
saw him on TV somehow these two hooked
or but yes so they hook and and they
were in like a three-year-long thing
where they would like quote/unquote
experiment with this thing that he said
he could do Ivan Budd eventually ended
up writing a book about him and all this
other side Isis but was show up with all
bunch of booze and get Ted drunk and and
give him a camera and a bunch of film
and Ted would try to take pictures of
his thoughts now the only thing he
needed is he had he needed this thing he
called it gizmo which was a rolled-up
tube of cardboard or paper it was like
black paper it usually came from because
usually I think they started out using
like kind of a traditional camera but
then you know as the 60s and 70s went on
they ended up using a Polaroid so I
think he used like the paper from like
some of the packaging ok rolled and
rolled it up into a tube and then he
would put his put his I put it on on the
lens of the camera and put it to his eye
that's how I remember him doing it did
that check out yeah and then he would
press it even they would press the
trigger to take a photograph yeah he
would either like have it in his hand or
something like that I said he needed it
I needed to focus his thoughts and his
focus keep the lights out and we're and
he had all these did he didn't he wasn't
sure he claimed that he didn't he didn't
really know how it worked
yeah well he felt like he had to have it
yeah and another thing he said to that I
thought was kind of interesting was that
even when you know these photographs
actually like had something on them he
was not it's not like he could predict
what the photo was gonna be beforehand
or anything like that it's like he was
always kind of like oh well it's not
that the picture is what I'm imagining
at the
moment it's almost more like he said it
was more like he was channeling it from
somewhere right so it's so it's not like
oh I'm getting control of it oh I'm
gonna think about you know a shavette
and then a picture of a shavette comes
out like he said it didn't really work
like that I guess it was a random
picture yeah now as I said this him and
this psychiatrist would do these
sessions now ted serios was a pretty bad
alcoholic yeah
he also and according to dr. Eisenbud
was also a sociopath he was not so he
was not like a real pleasant person to
be around
so these sessions where they would do
these photographs would sometimes last 8
to 10 hours
dr. Eisenbud would bring him vodka would
bring him alcohol and he would just get
drunker and drunker and as he got
drunker he would start like taking off
his clothes he would start like banging
his head on the floor he would start
just like you know just doing crazy [ __ ]
he would go infantile yeah he would just
start running and like start wailing and
crying and like all this other kind of
stuff like just running around the room
like an ape and all that kind of stuff
you know and kind of getting belligerent
toward like other people that had come
to see him so you know the meet he's a
fake though yeah my baby you might have
to work yourself up into some kind of
weird psychotic frenzy to do this we'll
see this is what I see this is the thing
that's always kind of kind of mystified
me about this case how do you how do you
fool these people that drunk
consistently because a from from what I
heard they never caught him they never
caught him slipping anything anything
into the tube or did they
did they okay what you might have newer
information or different information
yeah yeah okay yeah well you know you
can't base everything off of like the
old arthur c clarke show cuz i was but
honestly even that arthur c clarke show
had like two guys on there that said
that they knew how he did it okay tell
us more so but yeah but what I'm saying
is that so these long sessions would go
on he would ostensibly get drunker and
drunker
now I remember like when I heard about
this case as a kid just like you did um
I think I don't know if they really like
implied this on the show but I somehow I
got the idea that every time they would
take a picture it would come out and it
would be something and that was not the
case they said most of the time I think
of the tens of thousands of photographs
that were produced over the three years
that him and this psychiatrist worked
together four hundred of them had images
on them so that's not a big you know
percentage out of all the ones that were
taken so a lot of the other ones like I
said we're just of his face as it would
be if you just stuck the camera in your
face and took a picture of it or there
were some that were just all white or
all black which they called white ease
and Blackie's which I thought was very
funny because they just like said that
on the show just like okay that's what
you're calling them but that's what they
called them um and I think that Eisenbud
he thought that those were paranormal
also because he's like oh well there's
no way it could be all white or all that
they could be all white or all black and
I'm like I'm not sure I agree with that
but okay um you know what I mean so he
kind of counted those as paranormal
photographs too now again one of the
things that bothers me about this and
there was a lot of video taken of these
sessions there were really no scientific
controls undertaken
to the extent that I mean one video that
I saw there was three or four guys in
the room because sometimes they would
let like a bunch of people come and
they're just like you know bring a pack
of Polaroid film and you know we'll load
it up now one thing I don't think ted
serios ever held the camera himself I'm
not gonna say never but I'm in all of
the videos I saw someone else was
holding it it was usually joo eliza mode
was holding it or something like that
and then Ted would just kind of grab the
lens and you know make faces and [ __ ]
like that and do his thing to it so he
wasn't holding the camera okay not
usually but so people would bring the
film and everything but the way that Ted
acted like I said he he would be drunk
and sort of bullet he be kind of fallen
he's like taking his shirt off and all
this other stuff so I feel like in the
chaos it would be very very easy to fake
this [ __ ] because it didn't look like
anyone was trying particularly to keep
him from faking anything and I and I
definitely see and I definitely feel
like him engaging in all these
shenanigans was very distracting for
people you know what I mean because
there was like a bunch of people in the
room and he was like running around the
room or like you know on the floor doing
whatever he was doing and people's
there's guys over here guys over there
guys weren't even looking at him like no
one was looking at him you know what I
mean so I feel like it would have been
very very easy for him to fake things I
don't know we weren't there though no
but I just know from the video clips
that I've seen it doesn't really look
like anyone was trying very hard to you
know keep him from faking anything well
how do you fake it though very easily
it's been delegated by magician okay and
honestly somebody was telling me this
and I had forgotten all about these but
it used to be you remember back and I
think these were kind of big in the 80s
but there used to be you could get him
out of like quarter machines like it
[ __ ] the mall or whatever they were
like these little they were about this
big maybe a couple inches and it was
like a little plastic
case and there was like a lens in there
and then there was like a little bitty
transparency like in the back of the
thing and then you would looking it was
a it was essentially like a little teeny
like telescope and it had like a keyring
like it was like a keyring and so you
could look in there and then there was
like it was like ooh look it's the
Eiffel Tower or whatever I had I had one
that had like the Leaning Tower of Pisa
in it or something like that so you can
make something like that like pretty
easily and the fact that Ted had always
had to have this gizmo this little
cardboard thing they said now that would
have made it very easy to conceal
because some of the magicians that have
replicated this phenomena what they
would do is they would take a little
tube out an inch long about half an inch
wide and you would cut out a piece of a
35 millimeter slide and you'd put a lens
on one end and then you put the you'd
glue the little dot of the slide to the
other end and it's all and it's really
really small and you could actually fit
it inside the paper but then you could
palm it so when someone asked to see the
paper you'd be like look see there's
nothing in there but see it's it's so
much smaller than the paper that you
could just have it in between your
fingers and nobody would see it so it's
like if it's super small and if you hold
it up because a lot of the pictures that
ted serios produced looked pretty much
as though it's what it would look like
if you held a little picture up like
really close to the lens it's like this
little blurry picture was like dark
edges you know I mean like our dark
around the edges just like if somebody
had taken a picture of something out of
a book or blood or transparency and held
it up really close to the camera so if
you'd have when these old transparencies
with a lens on it you can hold it up to
a camera lens and get it yeah okay it
doesn't seem like it'd be possible yeah
now that's why some of the pictures of
well most of the pictures actually were
blurry because if you're just if you're
not like taking the time to like really
stick it in there like you'll get an
image but it'll be blurry right you know
don't be obvious see what
happening because it's it's a still
photograph so it's not like you can line
it up until it's perfect and then take
the picture because you wouldn't know
exactly you just have to do it it's just
by chance yeah and so I feel like that's
probably and as I said when I've seen
other magicians that have replicated
this and other like other photographers
that have replicated this that's how
they did it and the tube that they used
was so small that like I said you could
easily have just have it between your
palms and your fingers like between your
fingers and no one would see what had
ever caught with any of these little
things um I don't know if he was now
here's one thing though when these two
guys were there they asked him like
after photo was produced and they pulled
the you know Polaroid thing when he used
to hold the paper off the front then
they waited and there was actually an
image and they said hey Ted let's see
that paper thing and he stepped back and
put his hand in his pocket as though he
was like putting something in there and
then late he was like oh here like
handing them the paper so he did like
sketchy [ __ ] like that okay
and as I said the fact that you know I'm
not saying that that's how he did it but
it just seems to me that so many people
have been able to replicate this using
very simple means very and very and
especially like I said the videos that
I've seen of him you know no one is
attempting to keep him from doing that
there's nobody there like no you can't
use that no you can't but you know
nobody tied his hands to the table or
nothing like that it's just he's pretty
much allowed to do what he wants and
he's running around taking off his
clothes and yelling and whatever it is
he's doing acting like a crazy person
and then he's you know he's up there
making all those crazy faces in front of
the camera BAM and all that other kind
of stuff so he could be have this little
tube he could have it anywhere you know
I mean he could have in his mouth he
could have a who [ __ ] knows where it
is
it's really small like the ones that
have been used so I'm just saying you
know whether or not he did it like but
the fact that you can do that and
produce something that looks
pretty much exactly like the photos that
he produced gives me pause okay now the
only thing that sort of argues against
that and I'm not saying that there's not
an explanation for this but some of the
photos that were produced were I mean a
lot of them were buildings you know some
were cars and we're like you know it
usually wasn't people I mean some of
them they couldn't really tell what they
were cuz they were like all boring and
[ __ ] up looking but one of the
photographs interestingly appeared to be
the outside of dr. Eisen buds ranch but
it looked kind of different than the
ranch looked in real life you know I
mean like the window configuration was
kind of different
so I don't know if if that was actually
a picture of his house or if it was a
picture that he found of a house that
was similar you know so I don't really
know how that remember there was one of
them that was produced it was a picture
of a biplane and it looks pretty normal
yeah but somebody pointed out that the
struts that hold the top wing to the
bottom wing were we're opposite they
were yeah I was wrong for that airplane
yeah you know unless maybe it was a
photograph he found of a prototype
version of that plane without sweater
it's been a little bit different you
know yeah because there was a limited
edition version of that plane and people
didn't really know about it because yeah
or one plane if I remember correctly
yeah but yeah I remember seeing that one
yeah and things change very quickly in
World War one aviation you know every
month they made some kind of a change to
an airplane somewhere and maybe maybe
there was maybe that plane existed in a
limited edition that something was
backwards on it for a little while yeah
but it was weird you know some of stuff
they said now one of the photos I
remembered that they'd enter fied was
Ted said it was a caveman yeah
and they'll oh I know actually I have a
picture of that there they looked at it
and it was something it was a photograph
of a from Museum you see history history
it was like a Australopithecus sir yeah
Homo erectus yeah and I have a picture
of that to you yeah so that's what I
mean so the only thing that gives me
pause about it like I said and then and
actually then the other example of this
that I was thinking of was there was
this one that looked like they figured
out that it was a picture of an airplane
hangar that belonged to the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police but in the
picture which was blurry it looked as
though Canadian was misspelled yeah
that's right I remember that which
that's weird it is that that's pretty
weird but the it's blurry though so I
can't really tell if it's actually
misspelled or if it's just blurry and it
was looks like they're just weird
anomalies remember I was telling you
about the cat the cat vision how the
can't even like a had ears yeah it's
almost kind of like maybe if he was
projecting his thought onto a film it
was his version of it or and he didn't
spell Canadian maybe was misspelled in
his verse or maybe it was just done
quickly by the subconscious you know I
think that's what dr. Eisenbud was
arguing was that because I mean Joel
Eisenbud was like his big like advocate
and he kind of took him all over the
place and he did like like I said like
all these [ __ ] thousands of photos
and all these sessions with him and
ended up writing a book about him in
1967 called the world of ted serios but
you know as I said after their
three-year thing but I think that was
that was kind of what dr. Eisenberg was
proposing was that these images were
coming out of like a sort of a dreamlike
state where it wasn't as Ted was really
perceiving them but they were either
like being channeled through him which I
think ted serios kind of implied that or
that he was remembering them incorrectly
or was a manifestation of or in a
manifestation of the work
of a certain kind of subconscious
faculty within him you know I mean we
have many different facets to our
personality maybe that you know I mean
right and left hemispheres and maybe
it's just some kind of a an area of his
brain that just handled visual stuff you
know what I mean visual information but
not really spelling yeah he kind of knew
in general what the word Canadian looked
like but not close enough to know what I
was spelled yeah just the shape it's
it's weird though because I found like I
found it interesting that so many of the
photos that were produced or at least
the ones that I have seen and I think
all of them are at the University of
Maryland Baltimore campus they were all
given to the collection there so I think
you can I don't know if it's open to the
public but I thought you could go and
see them because I saw this lecture by
this parapsychologist I think his name
was Richard broad a broad e something
like that and he is like a big advocate
of Ted serieses work and he either
worked at the University of Maryland or
whatever so he's like seeing all the
photos and he thinks he's legit and he
thinks he's the real thing and he thinks
that he had like a this really powerful
like psychokinetic power but you know I
don't know it's it to me it just seems
like it's something that's too easily
faked and it you know it should be said
in 1967 which was the same year that the
book about ted serios came out that
Joule isin but had written these two
guys named Charlie Reynolds and David
Eisendrath they were they worked for
Popular Photography magazine and they
were also both magicians so they
arranged to spend a weekend with ted
serios and Jule Ivan Budd to see if they
could figure out what it was that he was
doing and they said that they saw ted
serios putting that little tube the
little tube into the paper tube
and then like not letting them check out
what it was you know what I mean yeah so
so yes so they actually it's interesting
because they wrote an article about it
saying you know if he was doing it this
is what he was doing and they explained
the whole like tube contraption and
everything and pretty much after that
article came out ted serios his career
was pretty much over because every you
know people were just like oh well
that's how he did it it was just a trick
and that was pretty much all she wrote
now they did have a reunion though
recently yeah oh he's dead now though
ted serios he died in 2006 I think okay
well before he died he got together with
that guy yeah he did yeah they had a
they had a trying to have another
session I watched it he couldn't produce
anything which I thought that was odd I
thought it that if that guy could fake
it he would at least fake it again once
yeah once he just thought [ __ ] it maybe
he thought like well if I don't do it
they'll think it was real yeah maybe he
was thinking that yeah because he said
well maybe I lost it I guess I lost it
yeah they looked like he was trying to
do it yeah and he evidently didn't drink
as much as he used to
yeah cuz that dude look like I mean it's
just funny like I guess not funny cuz
it's like alcoholism but you know you
see like videos of sessions with this
guy and there's some of them on YouTube
I'll probably put one video too and it's
just like he's just like taking a whole
body he saying you may have a glass or
nothing it's just like he just takes the
whole bottle of consuella and then you
know I mean I'm surprised he's still
standing up man cuz I mean even when he
first kind of came to the attention of
the paranormal world
he was already in his 40s by then so he
wasn't a young guy so I don't know how
long he had been doing that yeah and I
hadn't seen in a long time but I
remember him having kind of like [ __ ]
old greaser haircut look like old
greaser he did kind of yeah Oh duck bill
[ __ ] duck ass haircut in the back
like [ __ ] Elvis and [ __ ] yeah it
would it really quite that extreme but
yeah I see what you're getting Adam
rednecky kind of like a redneck yeah he
definitely did come off like that
he was he
seemed very yeah like old-school redneck
old-school redneck or like you know what
you reminded me he reminded me a little
bit of you know there's kind of yeah
there's like 50s like teen gang movies
as well where all the people in the teen
gang over 50 years old he reminded me of
that type of dude he's just like this
little wiry gang skinny yeah with all
these like crazy like [ __ ] facial
expressions like that he's just like
reminded me of that well so so after
this article came out about this
particular than these photographers and
magicians said oh you know he just has
like this little thing with the lens on
it and they're like a little you know
you you can make it yourself it's very
easy it's like you just cut out a little
piece of a photographic slide or
whatever and you just kind of stick it
on that and you stick it inside the
thing and no one can see it and you know
you push it up to the thing and it makes
a image and I've seen of like other
images that are you know that people
have said that they made it with that
method and they look pretty much exactly
the same um you know they're dark around
the edges there kind of smudging because
you didn't get them quite right so I
just kind of feel like that's probably
what he did okay
um so you're gonna say probably a fake
oh yeah say maybe it happened but
probably not I think it's an interesting
case it is he was like an interesting
dude and for a while it seemed like he
was kind of on all these paranormal
shows and it was just like he and he
seemed like such a character because of
all the drinking and all the crazy faces
and he like acted like a psycho all the
time like it was it might have been a
mixture of faking and some of it kind of
real because some of the anomalies in
those photographs are kind of odd unless
he would had the foresight to go out and
find anomalous photographs and get you
know get a negatives of those yeah
something that would just really impress
people when they saw it you know I mean
like yeah my Canadian misspelled on a
damn Canadian Air Force building
I just find it odd it's suspicious idea
although that mom totally discounted
that might even that might not have even
like been a photograph maybe maybe it
was just like an illustration from a
magazine and somebody didn't or
something like that maybe we don't know
well because I feel like some of the
images that I have seen because a lot of
them are online now because like I said
that the whole collection went to the
University of Maryland some of the
images that were produced look like they
have dot like dot matrix on them as
though he got them out of a newspaper
and now I should say too that I think
there was another magician later on who
said that they had seen ted serios and
he had a marble that had a picture like
stuck to it inside the model and a
marble yeah or like on the back of the
marble or something like that and then
he caught it and then he caught him with
that so I guess so that would work too I
guess you wouldn't even necessarily need
a lens I guess she would just if you had
like a clear marble you could kind of
stick a photo on the back of it and then
as long as you kind of pushed it into
the lens it would give you kind of a
creepy looking photo hmm it's funny
because some of the some of the photos
that he took that didn't really look
like anything cuz some of they were like
ooh looked creepy and I'm like that just
looks like the inside of your nose or
whatever but there was a couple that you
can really tell what they were and one
of them he tried to say was Ganymede
yeah it's one of the moons of Jupiter
right and I'm just like okay and he was
he said he regretted that he couldn't
get any like astronomer or anything to
get like on board with that I'm like
yeah I wonder why he did it
what the pictures look like what it
looks like when my camera goes off
inside my purse you know what I mean
so yeah it's that's the thing it's like
I could take one of the pictures that to
the my phone takes inside my purse when
it [ __ ] stays on and I touch it or
something
Cynthiana me yeah no I will see I would
be smart I would say it was from like
some undiscovered planet okay I'm not
gonna say it's something that we can
actually see with the Hubble Space
Telescope I'm not an idiot you know I'm
just gonna say that I'd you know keep it
so they can't prove it that's what you
got to do okay all right I was gonna say
that I always wondered why so many of
the photos that he produced were
buildings I guess he was maybe he was
just into that so like he'd go to the
library and he's like oh I like that
building and I like that building and he
just like cut it could be easy to find I
suppose they were easy to find
yeah cuz you wouldn't know like I said
you wouldn't necessarily have to use a
slide although I probably the easy if
you use the photograph or you could use
a negative if you use the photograph of
a person it would be too easy to track
down to track down where you got that's
yeah yeah that's a good point because if
you use buildings like I said you say a
picture of like the [ __ ] you know st.
Paul's Cathedral or there forever
Leaning Tower of Pisa there's like a
million pictures of that right so you
know it hard to place it in time it
would be harder and it would be harder
to go this exact photographing because
so many people have taken photographs of
it so yeah you're you got a point there
because I was sitting there wondering
it's like did he just really like
buildings or why it's like you know it
just seemed kind of weird like he'd say
he had a picture of one that was like a
Hilton Hotel and like some other city
around I think he was in Denver and
there was like a picture of the Hilton
from Chicago like where he lived or
something like that
but yeah so honestly like I said I'm not
gonna say a hundred percent that he was
faking but the fact that it would be so
easy to fake the fact that so many
magicians have done done it like that
and the photos look pretty much exactly
the same I kind of feel like that's
probably what he was doing and III just
don't think he because of all the
drinking because of all the chaos that
ensued when they were do these sessions
I just don't think anyone was paying
that close attention to him you know
what I mean I just think using as a
diversionary
tactic you get you're making diversions
yeah okay and like I said I think the
tube that he was using or the marble or
whatever it was like so small it's like
it would be super easy to just like
stick in your pocket or like roll it
under a table or under the dresser or
something like that no one would see it
yes you can have a couple of them
prepared for the night and then after
you did those ones you could just be
like oh I'm done now and then like all
the other ones wouldn't have to be
anything I'm gonna say it's an
interesting case I'd like to see it
again now but yeah it's been a long time
since I've seen the photographs that
everything good yeah yeah I've got some
of them all put him on I'll put him on
the YouTube show if you guys want to see
him look I said there's there's tons of
them all over the place you can see him
there I don't know if they had cuz for
awhile they had a whole website when
they had the exhibition up at the
University of Maryland and I think they
had almost all the photographs on there
like I said I think it was about 400
photographs but I don't know if it's all
on there anymore the the link is broken
but I did find quite a few of the
photographs and I found the caveman one
and you know I think I found one that
Canadian thing and stuff like that
alright so we're going to take a break
right now when we get back I want to
talk a little bit about kind of the
history of thought ography and you know
where the idea of it came from and like
maybe go into like some of the other
people that yeah because there's some
interesting stuff about uri geller -
yeah i think he was mostly a magician
but when he started out as imagine yeah
but there are some feats that he did was
pretty weird but you know then again
magicians could do weird [ __ ]
that's what see that's why I'm always
really really skeptical about all these
like psychic so these powers and stuff
like that I'm like if a magician can do
it right then I don't think you can do
it well okay we'll talk about all right
let's take a break we'll be back in just
a few
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide
the family massacre known as the good
heart murders the serial killings of the
Zodiac Bible John Jack the stripper and
the freeway phantom the slaughter of
dozens of women and girls along the
highway of tears and the Texas killing
fields and the mysterious death of
suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts buy it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format when you're doing laundry she's
out stand there what you doing what you
doing boy what you doing he's like don't
take every time we pour out the laundry
she runs underneath
[Music]
[Music]
right we are back talking about
photography
yeah and Jenny got me bummed out over
[ __ ] serious are you bum now I
thought I thought that dude probably dig
actually did that [ __ ] but I'm thinking
about it now he probably faked it like I
said I'm not saying definitively cuz I
wasn't there I'm just saying it would be
really really easy you really you ruin
my childhood you ruined my childhood
ain't that some [ __ ] I'm gonna face the
truth when it's time to face the truth
you know what I mean that's what I do
man childhood yeah I don't think that
dude did that yeah even though I don't
really like the amazing Randy too much
but I respect his game you know man if
he if he if he could replicate it then
that's probably what happened yeah it
was just him like I said other other
magicians have replicated it also right
but so like I said now photography as a
concept predated dead-serious by quite a
long way the first-known kind of mention
of it in the literature actually came
from 1896 and it was a book called the
new photography because it was a
newfangled [ __ ] back then photographs oh
my god you're capturing my soul by
Arthur Brunel Chatwood now it wasn't
called photography at the time that term
was coined a little bit later but he
actually in this book he talks about
experiments where it's like something
like [ __ ] that you saw or like objects
that you saw with like the retina of
your eye would like make such an
impression on you that if you looked at
this object and it made a super big
impression on dude then you looked at
like a light-sensitive plate you could
like yeah okay yeah so like I said that
was kind of what Tesla was saying well
that makes sense you know why if you
look at the Sun for too long all right
then you look great so that's what
they're talking about yeah it's not as
stupid as it
I was a kid you know we used to play
around with that kind of [ __ ] staring at
something you know for a long time and
then going into a dark room and looking
and you can kind of see that you see
like a negative of it against the wall
yeah yes that's what they're talking
about so yeah so it's not as like stupid
as it sounds because it does seem like
maybe shits going into your eye and then
you're like projecting it back out
because I do feel like they kind of you
know maybe by then that concept was sort
of on the way out but I do feel like
they were thinking oh [ __ ] like going in
your eye then shits coming out of your
eye like to see you know what I mean
so I feel like there was some of that
going on so that's like I said that's
going back to 1896 and wasn't there a
thing - I feel like I don't even
remember what it was but I feel like it
was maybe some movie about Jack the
Ripper or something like that where they
mentioned oh well if we take a you know
take a photograph or take like a
photographic plate of her retina of her
eyeball we'll see then we'll see the
murderer because I think there was like
some kind of weird urban legend about
how murder victims like would imprint
like a yeah like the last thing they saw
before they died like it'd be stuck on
their eyeballs so imagine imagine the
Ripper it was a home losing sleep over
that oh that probably look into a retina
see I didn't even think about that I
should have worn a mask and nowadays
we're just like it's finding yeah that's
not how it works but um yeah so I feel
like I've seen some [ __ ] worried they
thought that actually now that I'm
thinking about it I've seen some [ __ ]
movies maybe even like from their 40s
and 50s that still had that concept
right of you know there's a guy there's
a guy now he was in one of those band
TED Talks and he was one of the guys
that hangs out with who's the dude that
does all the the the Egyptian stuff
grant Hancock he's one of Graham Hancock
I wanna grant Hancock's friends had an
alternate theory that maybe vision does
come out of your eye oh yeah yeah I know
you're talking about they banned it they
banned that shitty cuz but it kind of he
was saying that it kind of made sense
though because that
Maddox explained the Heisenberg
uncertainty principles and other
uncertainty principles about objects
aren't affected until you look at them
yeah so he said maybe there is an
alternate or it's a two-way thing yeah
light does enter but also your
consciousness envelops the object that
you know I mean so anyway that's a
that's his theory it's I don't know it's
like okay I think I kind of heard part
of that dump that TED talk and it kind
of sounded dumb as hell but I'm not
really sure you know well not an optics
X what he was say he wasn't saying that
there would be you know he wasn't
putting forth any kind of evidence it
was all just a theory right that maybe
it was a two-way street you had light
coming in but you also had consciousness
coming out coming out yeah and that that
kind of not like it was your eyes like
you know that your consciousness kind of
enveloped things through a process of
vision and you know you know well you
guys can watch the TED talk for yourself
that's out there yeah it seen it so it's
not like it's yeah him and Grant Hancock
are also talking about you know highly
psychedelic drugs like ayahuasca you
know but so Joe Rogan and altered states
of consciousness are real they really do
that really do those things really do it
otherwise people wouldn't take your hugs
yeah and there have been a lot of people
who have actually come up with awesome
songs and artworks and inventions in
altered states of consciousness you know
some people are saying that these guys
on Silicon Valley up in Silicon Valley
or
microdose in LSD well that's a big thing
in and that just small doses of LSD can
keep creativity going and if you've ever
[ __ ] with you that people we've never
[ __ ] with that we have no I would
never do that there may be something to
that there may be something to that
because well I could see that sure yeah
because you can think kind of sideways
under these weird drugs and come up with
some weird solution to a problem that
you'd you know maybe it may be a
solution to a problem you hadn't
envisioned yet just weird [ __ ] like that
yeah but it's not just that alone you
know set to be a trained physicist or a
train you know I mean you have to have
other skills well anything that is gonna
get you like you said thinking along a
different line than you normally would
rise I feel like most people in their
everyday
lives you know your your thought gets
kind of placed along yeah railroad
tracks because it kind of has to be you
know you got to do the same thing
everyday like routine and everything
you're not used to like branching out in
all these different directions so you
can see why people take psychedelics I
the I do is look at the Mexicans and the
Mesoamericans you know the Incans Mayans
the Aztecs Toltecs and all those they
were into all that they took all those
weird as drugs and they had technology
technology that people don't realize
that they had many but kind of with
calendars there were super advanced
calendars super advanced thinking now a
lot of stuff is destroyed but the
Spanish of the time even some of the the
friars and the monks that that the
church sent down there they were up in
arms about destroying that stuff they're
saying this is valuable yeah
technology and information that these
guys had thousands of years of research
and work on philosophy and calendars and
[ __ ] like that you know and that came
from all that stuff they see in [ __ ]
around them damn drugs like I said I
think that is probably the best thing
about psychedelics and other drugs of
that ilk is that they they almost force
your brain to make connections that it
wouldn't make otherwise because like I
said you you get into everybody gets
into patterns with their thinking
especially you know the older you get
you can get kind of set in your ways you
get used to doing things in particular
way so I think it's very useful to take
something that will you know cause
synapses to fire that wouldn't
necessarily like we're in a different
order it makes connections that you
wouldn't necessarily if you take a dumb
[ __ ] and you give him that kind
so he just does silly [ __ ] ok take a
genius and a genius who can't solve a
certain problem you've been working on
it forever and you give him that there's
a chance that that might help him find
that fine fine well it's just like has a
very imagination based yeah you know
well it's just like how sometimes and
I've had this happen to me as well that
you know you kind of run into a problem
especially if it's like a creative
problem like I say I'm writing a novel
and I'm like it's some plot point I
can't figure it out or whatever and then
you'll be like stressing out about it
then you have a dream right and it like
sorts it out for you and you're just
like oh yeah yeah Einstein said that he
would see things in little micro G yeah
yeah be napping a little bit [ __ ] oh
that's what it is and then you go figure
it out yes altered states of
consciousness are actually do help
because your waking consciousness is
actually pretty weak compared to all the
other subroutines and stuff going on
inside the subconscious that yes there's
a lot of [ __ ] that's going on that's
doing all the heavy lifting and that's
what you have to access and that's what
Transcendental Meditation hardcore
sensory deprivation weird [ __ ] like that
and then some of these psychedelics are
kind of shortcuts to it yeah exactly
that same like I said which is why I
think they're very useful right but yes
so so the whole thoughtography thing
like I said it came from the idea that
you could somehow project your thoughts
or project something that you had seen
onto a light-sensitive plate which like
I said it doesn't it sounds kind of
crazy but not if you think about it in
the context of the time and even if you
think about in the context of now it
doesn't really sound all that weird
because you know look at we have MRIs
and we can like to look inside people's
bodies you can look inside people's
brain and see their brain waves it's
[ __ ] like that so I don't think it's
that nutty but the term photography
actually comes from Japan I think it was
first coined in 1913 and this was a guy
named Tim okichi foo kurai and he was
probably the first guy to like work on
this thoughtography thing like as the
kind of like main thrust of his research
something that I didn't realize until I
was researching this show was that you
guys you know the movie the ring that
came out in 2002 it's a remake of the
Japanese movie Ringu and I've seen that
one as well but I can't remember if this
was an aspect of the original Japanese
film or not but I know it was in the
American remake where the early days of
photography in Japan that's kind of
loosely where the inspiration for the
ring came from because the little girl
that comes out of the TV and kills
people and whatnot she thought these
horrible images onto the cursed video
that's how they got there
she didn't record them or anything it
just it came out of her brain and came
out of her subconscious and then when
people watched the video you know then
she comes and gets them like they'll die
seven days later and then the curse is
passed along and [ __ ] like that so
there's kind of like scenes where they
show this little girl and she they're
kind of researching her because she can
do this kind of [ __ ] so I was like I
didn't even realize that until I was
like don't what cuz I [ __ ] love that
movie it's good the [ __ ] out of me when
I saw it the first I've ever seen it
you've never seen the ring oh it's so
good it's so good you got to see it I
saw it in the theater when it came out
like I said I came out 2002 and I saw
the original later and I liked it but I
this is one of the cases where the
American remake I think was actually
better than the Asian original which is
usually not the case yeah but I think in
this case it really was like that the
video of it was so creepy and [ __ ] I got
so many Japanese ones that I'm behind on
that I had that I have to see I still
haven't seen to see i Tetsu you Iron Man
that's on shutter yeah I don't see that
one I haven't seen it yet I've seen it
but it was a long time ago you should
also see old boy oh boy saw parts of
that is also on yeah shudder I saw like
the first 1/3 of it and I forgot what
happen I think I got interrupted yeah
yeah but trying to figure out where he
was based on the damn potsticker noodles
yeah you you dare call yeah c'mon dude
it was a Korean movie wouldn't it
because he was he was talk about yakkin
yakkin yeah yeah nah c'mon dude this was
Korean noodle potsticker noodle yeah
what do they call them dumplings
yeah dumplings I love them another one
you should see which is actually uh I
think it's actually Chinese but you
should see one called the I okay do not
see the American remake it is an
abortion but the original is actually
really good but you should see the ring
the American remake Naomi Watts was in
it who was in Mulholland Drive which is
if you've done movie please watch our
movie retrospective you know it's like
one of my favorite movies ever but she
was in the ring and it was I saw in the
theater and it for real scares the crap
out of me and that's saying something
because I love horror movies and they
don't usually bother me
but that one creeps me the [ __ ] out I
don't know why there was something about
that video like the video images it was
like it was just like super creepy but
yeah that was based on thoughtography
because the little girl had projected
these creepy images onto this video tape
that subsequently went on to kill people
so let's talk a little bit about so Tim
ekishu Fuu karai
he started kind of looking into this
whole thoughtography thing and he
started working with a bunch of women in
Japan that were mediums that claimed
they could do this type of stuff that
they could project their thoughts on to
film so interestingly he had one called
Shizuka buffoon a-and then he had one
called Ikuko Nagao and she was the main
one that he worked with that said she
could like tell telepathically imprint
images onto photo plates now this you
know like I said he called it
photography which he actually called it
men show which I guess sort of sort of
translates to spirit photography even
though like I said spirit photography in
English that's not really the same thing
because that's usually like that
Victorian thing where they put gross
[ __ ] photos but so that's what they
called it over there it's like ninja and
tog Rafi or something like that for
ghost spirit and psychic and all that
stuff is probably all kind of rolled
into one thing yeah I just means you
know paranormal photo paranormal ghost
[ __ ] yeah but yeah the thing is so he
had done like all of these similar type
of things to you know ted serios type
things were she's like look at all these
creepy photos that she produced but
apparently some journalists or whatever
came to investigate thought it that it
was fraudulent or thought that they
caught them in a lie or something like
that and the girl the woman at kuku
Nagao she actually ended up dying later
like pretty young from now I've seen
illness I've seen suicide probably so
yes so I don't know if like some people
said oh she got some horrible illness
because of all the stress because she
got a key
being fraud or whatever this Japan
probably suus or she may be off herself
I'm not really sure now so even though
fook are I actually published a book
about the phenomena in 1913 which i
think is where the term photography
comes from but it kind of got braked
over the coals by the scientific
community at the time he just said the
you know lack of controls he didn't do
the test right blah blah blah and he was
kind of he worked for a university at
the time but he kind of got [ __ ] on and
he ended up having to quit like later
that year so that whole thing happened
there and as I said before when when I
was talking about the movie the ring
they actually coined the term projected
thermography okay but they they I
believe they coined that for that movie
but they just but the paranormal
community has kind of taken that term on
so thoughtography and projected
thermography are now interchangeable
terms even though I'm pretty sure that
that's that that came from the movie so
there was also now I think this is
particularly where the thing for the
rain came from because one of Fuuka rise
other subjects was named Sadako
takahashi now pretty sure correct me if
I'm wrong but the girl in the ring was
called Sadako I thought she was so I
think that's kind of where that's where
that came from as well now let's talk a
little bit about um yeah so [ __ ] all
right he died in the 50s but he
established it like a paranormal you
know Institute or whatever so that's so
he's kind of like the father of
thoughtography I guess so let's talk a
little bit about this other medium and
her name was Eva Carriere now she was
another one that sort of did a
thoughtography type thing although what
she did was kind of more in line with
your classic seance type manifestations
what she would do is she would produce
ectoplasm but the ectoplasm would have
pictures of people in it didn't come
from avange did it
never you gotta understand some folks
ectoplasm if you really look into the
record a lot of times ectoplasm came
from the vag well because that's the
hide behind it yeah there's say you know
there was a very bodily kind of smell
very feminine kind of a smell we don't
know why it happens but it just does
yeah it's like I wonder I really wonder
why does ectoplasm always smell like my
wife's cooch snatch photos UNAM actually
the photos that I've seen of IVA
Carriere she usually had the ectoplasm
coming out of her mouth or out of the
sides of her side of her head or
something like that
but one of the best here here's the
thing about a lot of these mediums and
especially if you I mean if you're doing
this [ __ ] cuz some of the tricks they
pulled were pretty elaborate right so if
you're doing that [ __ ] I can see why
it's like you know we can't have any
lights on in the room it's like no
photographers no sería ticks nothing
like that I've seen photographs well I
know but so she was dumb enough to be
like sure you can take photographs look
a fake his [ __ ] yeah so one photograph a
very famous one of her that was taken um
because I guess she what she would do is
she was producing the active plasma it
had like people's faces in it she would
say their ghost faces I'm producing them
from my body or whatever now someone
took a picture of her from the opposite
side like from where the face was
appearing and where the face was you
could clearly see that she had cut
someone's for him pictures on his face
out of a magazine yeah like I don't know
where these mediums got the idea for
ectoplasm I mean see now I feel like we
discussed that on some other show but it
just like this is so intriguing to me I
remember the yeah like I remember cuz I
was super into like normal
when I was good and I feel like wow for
any new listeners I've had a paranormal
experience Jenny's had a paranormal
experience with me - with poltergeist
and which is a long time when I was a
kid my whole family anyway I never saw
anything like ectoplasm the closest
thing to ectoplasm I foresaw was that
blue haze yeah blue haze and kind of
weird kind of halo type things around
objects that we're getting ready to move
but but it was hard stuff it was really
there or not you couldn't look directly
at it yeah it was almost kind of like
you were definitely looking at a some
kind of a an anomaly it wasn't a solid
you know you're definitely looking at
something in the realm with a [ __ ]
physics energy or quantum something you
know Who am I you know I can't put words
to any of this kind of [ __ ] it's just
but when you see photographs of
ectoplasm from these séances that's
obviously cotton or cheesecloth
cheesecloth was cut out little
photographs of people laid on them yeah
you know I mean when you take a picture
of it with a flash that when I first saw
that I first saw that as a kid but it
was after the mammoth mountain thing
went down ya know I looked at that and I
almost believed it it was like wow you
know I mean but then I was gone no that
can't be that can't be I didn't ever saw
anything like that there's it was weird
looking well yeah that makes sure's
that's what I mean and it was really
weird the same kind of thing about all
the seance photos and ghost photos that
I saw at that Museum exhibition it's
like even if you know they're fake
you're still yeah weird picture yeah
like creepy look I'm like 14 15 16
running across these photographs after
after seeing that thing when I was 13
you don't and I'm almost entertaining it
for a second yeah I'm going now can't be
I mean because I was looking for what
happened to me and my family over and
over again and right yeah just weird you
know and you just can't you can't
photograph you can't photograph things
like ectoplasm I expect people to
[ __ ] believe it when it's mad [ __ ]
cheesecloth and [ __ ] yeah because
closest thing
anything that me and my family ever saw
with people taking photographs of little
things sitting on steps and little
objects sitting on things and you know I
mean yeah because that's what a
poltergeist event looks like when you
try to photograph it you know a rocking
chair upside down yeah you know that's
it see I always kind of wondered though
like you said it's like where did the
concept of ectoplasm originated for like
I'm trying to project myself back in
time I'm a fraudulent medium what sales
right that's what I was thinking and I
want to do like a seance I'm gonna do
something that nobody's done before so
everybody'll come to mine and give me
money why this why that
yeah why would you think of that oh I'm
gonna take a piece of cheesecloth and
put pictures in it and stick it up my
couch yeah and then pull it out and be
like oh it's look at that so it's ghost
snot coming from my body what the [ __ ]
it's like why would you even think of
that
and then I remembered acid that's what
it was a long time ago I read people who
giving their accounts of what happened
in a seance and they believed it 100%
that the whole thing was spiritual and
paranormal but they also said they could
tell there was a lot of sexual energy in
the air and that you know I mean that
the medium was basically showing her
cooch off or you know I mean it was like
yeah it was like wow yeah and that they
could swear that masturbation that she
made she said like she'd had an orgasm
to me and his masturbating
well that might explain it and yeah and
these are people from you know the 1800s
Early 1900s
yeah and for some reason I would have
hustler for some reason though this is
adding more credibility just seance I
don't really understand that what he was
a sheltered time well yeah because I
guess it was the kind of thing where you
couldn't do that stuff in quote-unquote
polite company Oracle of Delphi oh yeah
that's what they're talking about tell
them what the Oracle of Delphi magnesian
Greek days they had these Oracle's and
there were these young girls and they'd
stick them in this [ __ ] little cave
and these gases would come out of the
[ __ ] ground
they were noxious and poisonous and they
poison the damn girl but she'd start
hallucinating and she'd be able to give
out these prophecies and evidently they
did a bunch of kind of sexual stuff too
because their brains were frying well
yeah so it's probably what what they're
they're drawn a damn conclusion between
the Oracle of Delphi yeah type stuff
well and you know what's interesting too
as a sort of a segue off of that going
back to talking about Eva Carriere there
were allegations at the time that her
Confederate that these seances you know
the person that was sneaking around like
doing all this [ __ ] was her girlfriend
yeah and that they would have sex
afterwards and I also read and I don't
know if this is true or not but that if
you were at the seance and you wanted to
get in on that [ __ ] they were down yeah
as long as you paid yeah yeah there's
like hey can I join in well why not
it kind of would mean there were those
kind of girls he kind of makes sense if
you looked at it from the period of time
you know late Victorian era yeah I mean
early 1900s people had kind of class
educated people have very classical
education and then it was a lot of stuff
about you know ancient Greeks and
ancient Rome and stuff and that stuff
was prevalent in in those old cultures
in terms of you know like the war at
Delphi and sooth you know soothsayers
and [ __ ] like that it's probably what
they're talking about yeah I guess I
talked about the sexuality is a
heightened they've seen sexuality is
kind of like a heightened state of
awareness yeah you know what there is
what they're doing it free from earthly
yeah I mean from the earthly bounds of
Victorianism you know yeah it's got to
be true I mean they're [ __ ] that's
what they're saying you know basically I
always wondered too if like the whole
ectoplasm thing because I mean 99% of
the mediums for women was it almost like
they were manifesting like Siemens
you know they talked about that I think
they said it was me
his bodily smells this smell blade but
maybe that's where they got seem in it
well maybe that's where they got the
idea from it's like just you're
transcending [ __ ] gender you know I
mean that's why that's what I think
they're talking it's like oh well men
can shoot jizz out of their bodies I'm
Annette well now I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna shoot out of my fingers and you
know there's a legend of how this may
have been just the scene of the day you
know this is the this is the [ __ ]
hardcore God you know I mean like an
alternative seeing as you see these
séances and sex might have and then yeah
you paid to show up there but you didn't
pay for sex of course not well yeah and
it was a spiritual [ __ ]
that's how you like justified it just
like the ancient Greeks and [ __ ] yeah
nobody cared who who was you know male
or female it was all just you know
[ __ ] love fast yeah so it's true
paranormalist [ __ ] I'm getting all kinds
yeah transit now I think that's what
they're talking about it could be yeah
it's less weird in that context yeah
because we go back and you you look at
like not Anton LaVey was it a guy was
thinking of Aleister Crowley Aleister
Crowley that was the same kind of spiel
he would give you yeah that you know
long as you were having sex and it had
to be true it had to be real you know I
mean that's kind of I think that's what
they're talking about
I feel like cult leaders all over the
world of yeah that [ __ ] out well it was
a different time
yeah it's a different time now I'd be
like whatever you like make it a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah it's like now they have
never gonna be like pull that [ __ ] off
ever again so yeah that I wasn't did
weren't thinking that that's the
direction yeah well look I said what now
that we've kind of like drilled down on
it in that direction it doesn't seem
quite as weird as part of what was going
on
although cuz I always wondered about
that act applies it's like who the [ __ ]
was the first person that came up with
that it's a union of female and male and
it's coming out of a woman and people
can see it and it's got it
you know you paid to see it it's that
kind of [ __ ] you don't I mean yeah back
then it was mysterious you know yeah
yeah all right so all right so after ted
serios had kind of like fallen out of
favor after this photography after these
two guys at the photography magazine had
kind of written about him and said cuz
it's pretty much accuse him of being a
fraud it was actually this other guy in
Japan and his name was Misaki Kyoto and
I think when he first came to the
attention of the media I think he was
only 16 years old now he said that he
had psychokinetic powder powers and
could do the same thing that ted serios
could do like you know put images onto
film now a TV station in the UK was
interested in this and invited Minnesota
okay well come on the show and do it so
they put him on the show but he couldn't
do anything and then they're like the
only way that he could quote-unquote
project mental images onto the film like
he said he could do yeah was if you gave
him the package of film and let him go
sit by himself in a room for two hours
with it
which seemed a little fishy but he
didn't ask for that at the beginning no
but but he didn't he couldn't do
anything yeah but they said that was the
only way that he could you just like you
let him sit in there for a couple of
hours with some film and then later ooh
miracle of miracles he would praise like
all these ever mind
the images that reminds me of Uri Geller
and the day that he goes on with the
Merv Griffin Show
yeah was the Merv Griffin Show and when
the amazing Randi handed him the other
you know handed him that what was that
they they were little [ __ ] vials
yeah they saw the guest something was in
there remember that one yeah I can't do
it I can't do it
yeah because the end like sent [ __ ] up
beforehand right now see uri geller who
for a time probably the most famous
psychic in the world yeah yeah look I
tell you something I've seen all reruns
his shows and I remember seen him when I
was a kid he was an awesome showman he
was here's the awesome showman and in
later years you might have said that
that's all he was sound like a David
Copperfield but he was very spiritual he
make you feel good yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean now he kind of ran the gamut like
you know he could bend spoons he could
stop Fox he could do this now the other
thing but he claimed he could do
thoughtography as well now what he would
do starting in the mid 1990s is that
they would give him a 35-millimeter
camera and it still has a lens cap on it
and he would hold it up to his forehead
and take a picture with the lens cap
still on and then magic like all these
[ __ ] aim it's just like the ten
serious ones would supposedly come out
he's like I'm taking pictures of my
thoughts right so okay but the only
problem with that was that what he would
do he he would pretty much do the same
thing that they suspect had serious
would do that he had a like a little
lens thing like in his hand that he
would palm or that he had had some type
of already exposed film already in there
you know that they would then it would
be like a double exposure and then one
time they actually gave him the camera
and he was left alone with it for a few
minutes
and when they when they developed the
pictures okay so the camera had a
fisheye lens which he did not know about
so the picture that was produced was him
taking off the lens cap and because it
was a fisheye
you could kind of see around so you
could see around the lens cap and you
could see him right behind there like
twisting the lens cap I'll examine and
[ __ ] open this up and so they had a
picture of him doing that because he
didn't know it was a fisheye lens he
thought it was just a normal lens so
they actually kind of caught him fake
well they caught him faking on several
occasions I mean uh and on one show I
can't really show it was but they caught
him bending a spoon like against a table
edge when he thought nobody was looking
at him you know he did [ __ ] like that
which that's the thing uri geller
started out as a magician and then later
on he segue that into like Lou I'm doing
some spiritual [ __ ] yeah he's kind of be
like I'm like a Mentalist like a
Mentalist
yeah which the thing about it is that
you know magicians Mentalist stuff like
that
obviously they do these types of tricks
like all the time
what they hate are people that come out
and say I have several powers and that's
how I can do it they're like no you
don't you know it's like if you know
that that's what you're getting you know
yeah we're entertaining people we're
doing magic you know it's not real
you're the trick you agree Geller didn't
have [ __ ] on Criss Angel remember
Christmas
I don't trail Chris they do way better I
saw one with Chris changer where Chris
angels getting run over by a bulldozer
it's obvious that there's a hole cut in
the grass
God man that dude you looked at Chris
angel you find out that he had a
background of special effects yeah and
course and all the witnesses and all the
crowds that are watching him they're all
plant they're all plants the entire
thing so you know you might as well not
watch chris angel who is the who's the
other one the one dude that we're like
he hurt himself by the street magic guy
yeah well he was actually super good I
thought so yeah now was it him or the
other guy or was a him or Chris angel
that had the person lay down on the park
bench and then pulled them in half
sounds like some Criss Angel would do
but I'm not I'm not
it was I mean obviously it was a trick
but it was cool it was cool but the guy
that you're talking about the ones
magic I can't remember his name David
Blaine David Blaine I just remember
David Blaine was an awesome little
magician but he actually did some
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] like he was in that
damn yeah he did like a Snape artist
kind of like a yeah he was in that
sphere filled filled with water
yeah for that block of ice yeah and he
was in that water for several days yeah
it [ __ ] his kidneys up yeah he that
was the last that was the last stunt
that he did I don't fail dat that one
yeah because he failed you know that he
actually was doing those well works of
endurance that's the thing it's like and
and people say it's about Houdini to
like it you know it's not really
accurate scald a magician I mean they
call them an escape artist because like
they're Devils to do yeah because that
you were really doing it I mean they
really did put Houdini in a milk can and
like did it with change this up yeah he
had lock picks and stuff like that but
yeah couldn't get out people he dies
he'll die people have died doing those
trick people have died doing those
tricks well that magician we're watching
that one the other day where you know
that that very famous trick will they
put you in a coffin and then like they
bury you area or just clone you have to
get out but some magicians have died
doing that because they're actually in
there if the dirt you know collapses in
on them it will kill you yeah and it
does happen and it has happened yeah oh
yeah and also guys have been thrown into
those damn tanks of water and then they
throw that [ __ ] into the [ __ ] ocean
and they gotta come out of there and
they never make it out yeah you know
yeah because like I said they are real
it's not a trick they are really in
there I still got I got mad respect for
Blaine and I wish Blaine would come back
yeah I haven't seen David Blaine in a
long time although like I said I
wouldn't blame him because he evidently
they did some hardcore that last that
last one nearly killed him yeah yeah
he'd [ __ ] his kidneys up you can't
remain submerged for that amount of time
well now because the water actually goes
into your body yeah seeps in [ __ ] see
Katie well like I said was he was in
that frozen block of ice for a long time
to in 48 hours yeah I think it was
longer than that my name in 72 hours and
wasn't he up didn't they put him like on
top of this really but high like obelisk
or yeah they stuck him on top of an
obelisk and he was up there for [ __ ]
days and days and days
yeah yeah he had diapers on in the cafe
I would hope you know that's what I was
saying I'm like oh God yep they're
[ __ ] yourself yeah test of endurance
and then you have to like change your
own diapers and you have to stay awake
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] that but yeah I'm
seeing now I kind of want to go watch
that Washington David Blaine yeah it
might have been Criss Angel that one
that where he pulled that guy in half
like I'd like I said I know it's a
change but he was a lot of over-the-top
[ __ ] that was obviously special effects
yeah well I the thing I liked about
David Blaine was that he did like Street
magic yeah a little small stuff you know
what I mean which it was string out of
his side you know yeah injected it in
there it was actually alien yeah but I
like the one that he did where he would
like throw a card and it would like turn
up on one yeah other side of like yeah
glass it looks paranormal but it wasn't
no yeah I can't figure out how they do
it but I know it's a trying though but
that see that's the thing
I mean I'm fascinated by this kind of so
I'm not a magician like I dunno how a
lot of tricks are done but I'm just
fascinated by that kind of [ __ ] and I
love like trying to think about how
they're done but that's why I'm so
skeptical of you know obviously mediums
back from the old is like in seances and
stuff like that but I'm skeptical and
people like ted serios i'm skeptical of
people who do this type of stuff like in
a you know even in a lab environment and
stuff because if a magician can
replicate it then most of the stuff that
happened in a seance and a Victorian
seance wasn't even as good as what a
magician could do exactly weren't that
good yeah because they were just they
probably just came into it yeah well
it's just an even kind of like some of
the UM they had hidden people assistants
yeah like I said they had like
Confederates in the background that were
like hidden behind you know walls or
like in cabinets or whatever that would
pop out in the dark and ooh [ __ ] you
know but even [ __ ] like some of the
people that they used to test for you
know
psychokinesis and they would like you
know lean over a table and move stuff
they were doing that with like a piece
of thread like just perfect just simple
[ __ ] that you wouldn't even heard they
were blowing on it or something
it's just simple [ __ ] that is easy to do
without being detected
but unless there's a magician they're
looking at you and be like hey they've
got a piece of thread you wouldn't
necessarily think of it because you
can't see it and it looks like they're
doing something magic if we get
sidetracked from photography probably
business mother I'm both drinking I'm
drunk you still you drinking still well
like I said I mean when you said we're
gonna do the ted serios show instead
yeah there's not a huge amount about
thoughtography because it's kind of its
heyday was in japan in the early 20th
century yeah and then there was you know
some [ __ ] with ted serios he was kind of
like that was components yeah like uri
geller did some stuff but he kind of got
caught faking and he was mostly famous
for spoon bending and stopping watches
and that kind of stuff more than
thoughtography I feel like it's it's an
interesting it's kind of a shame because
it's really an interesting ask that you
but it's faked it's still kind of an
interesting as well you're not gonna see
it anymore because photographs are gone
yeah sure they don't do photography
anymore but I'm most I like looking at
the photos it's just kind of like the
Victorians period spirit photography
even though I know that they're fake
they're still like fascinating to look
at because I just like love that kind of
[ __ ] because the premise was is that it
was the mind actually [ __ ] with the
chemical properties of film right see so
that's gone film is rare now yes now if
it was um if you could actually do it
through some kind of psychokinetic power
then you'd think you'd be able to do it
on a digital camera - yeah you think
it'd be easier because it was just like
cheers my pixel like lighter vessels you
could just put whatever you want it in
there so I feel like there's probably
and I didn't really look that up but I
feel like
maybe there's some digital thought I
appreciate going on - I think I actually
think there's a band called too easy to
fake well that's what I mean well and
that's kind of a problem now - and I
think that's why a lot of people are
fasten it but like these old spirit
photography and stuff like that because
now like I said I have Photoshop I can
make a photo of whatever the [ __ ] you
want right in less than an hour
depending on how complicated it is so
and it's like and I can make it look
real it and RIT and a lot of people can
do that so I feel like nowadays it's
like Oh picture didn't happen it's like
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] I took a picture of
him as a kid yeah and put it into a
picture with Evel Knievel with Evel
Knievel and I look like I belong what's
real
I had my STP jumpsuit never had a little
SD that's when I was lying to people
online it was joke though I was telling
them that I was actually hired in at the
age of seven okay as a consult as a
consultant to give a knievel during his
Snake River Canyon job I met with a
rocket sherry Feynman all everyboy back
in the seventies we were little boys we
knew about Evel Knievel and the Snake
River Canyon jump we have a little
windup [ __ ] Evel Knievel toys with
the [ __ ] motor in motorcycles and
[ __ ] yeah my brother had that's why I
ride bikes today really Evel Knievel
yeah well that was a big deal yeah I
remember that yeah but yeah I did I
[ __ ] love Evel Knievel that hit
[ __ ] was an [ __ ] go look up
some shows his interviews with Evel
Knievel that was the ultimate 70s man
yeah yeah very much so
yeah ultimate 70s American man he was
like a modern-day gladiator yeah well
like I said I think that's why he
resonated with a lot of people yeah like
that was a big deal when he was doing
that from yeah anyway and the
[ __ ] was a psychopath yeah oh
yeah yeah use a nuts but that's you have
to be nuts to do that kind of you didn't
care if your dad wrote mad respect for
you but can you broke every [ __ ] bone
in his body
yeah you can watch it live in slow
motion or you can watch it again in slow
motion to him just crises
yeah but yeah I did a whole series I did
one of you and evel knievel
yeah I did one of me go go go yeah that
was actually my favorite yeah we used me
up as a boy to I barely survived that
too
I barely [ __ ] survived I don't know
if I can find out I don't know if I can
find out they're on Facebook me hanging
out with [ __ ] Andrew eldritch yeah
yeah I've been to but we won I mean you
buddy Freddy murder was that time Freddy
merton Freddy let me go up there and
[ __ ] hang out on stage damn I made a
whole bunch of them I also made actually
my other favorite woman the go-go's one
was my favorite cuz yeah just because
the picture I found of the go-go's it
was like perfectly conducive for like
adding another person in and it looks
like Belinda Carla cuz she was going
like that while like with her arm and it
looked like she had her arm round you
know I was like oh my god this is
beautiful I was so young I don't know
how I survived that tour man those girls
were so demanding and me I'd they're
just sucking me dry yeah it was like
that she had a Dracula
remember when he became a man that day
on that tour no the other one I did this
my second favorite one was I did a cover
of teen beat or Tiger Beat AGGA be
targeted had a pig was on the planet
ography he was uses I gotta find that
there on your Facebook page
Oh head then jet black hair I was [ __ ]
lily-white skin look like a I was
prettier than Tom Cruise when he was you
looked a bit like Tom Cruise but not
quite you had kind of a neat sound
cruise I had a better nose than Tom
Cruise yeah yeah I don't I don't know
Tom Cruise has always been he's I'm talk
about Tom Cruise from the legend era
back when he was on I know yeah I
thought he was kind of weird-looking so
I'm saying I was better looking at him
yeah I think you were yeah and and you
had that like it was the 80s so you had
that kind of it wasn't the same hair it
was
a mullet it was like this but it was
like feathered Jesse's girl yeah [ __ ]
Demi Moore's little brother you say well
it's just kind of like with it the last
review we were talking about the car
racing those pictures Aussie yeah I'll
find him there on your Facebook page I
think but um we're talking about the
[ __ ] horrible skinny coke [ __ ] pants
that they have these 70s the 80s I don't
know what our excuse was cuz I wore some
cocaine I was not on cocaine about but I
didn't wear I didn't wear a super
horrible [ __ ] but I did have um you know
how everybody had like super big hair
mine was not super fit although my bangs
were super big you know how everybody
likes the the back of the hair was kind
of flat but then in the front like you
kind of like spiked up the bangs there
were like these big [ __ ] bangs in the
front I had that you know yeah and
everybody had that I had Aussie hair
spray yeah everybody I knew and how
y'all had that smell hair spray smells
every time every time well I think it's
like metal great metal or whatever the
[ __ ] it is that they put in there but
every time cuz they still make Aussie
you guys so as sometimes I was the same
yeah sometimes I'll buy it and every
time I spray it my hair I'm like high
school high school every girl I knew in
high school junior high and high school
in the 80s I had been gym head hair
spray in their locker and they had been
shaking my hair I legit yeah yeah black
black hair Billy out yeah did you ever
wear parachute pants no I didn't
although I did have a pair of dark red
corduroy pants that had a bunch of
zippers all over them which I guess was
cut well they weren't really like
parachute pants because they weren't
puffy they were pegged we're doing a
show you're talking about high school
okay I told you could go off on tangents
cuz it wasn't long straight segments
I don't know 48 minutes 48 minutes is a
[ __ ] two hours chef it is yeah okay
yes you there and we mostly mostly
talked about spirit photography kind of
most of the show it's not spirits
photography psychic photography yeah you
know no psychic photography even know
what I mean
and I'm getting back to it serious I
thought there was something to it but
now that now that she's now that she's
sucking brought forth this new
information I'm gonna say that he was
faking it it was a good story though you
know I don't I don't like to poop on
people's birthday cakes but yeah I
thought there might have been something
to it but no probably not
this is just kind of like that whole
pterodactyl in the cave there are you
taking me back to that one well it's
well the thing is I think that a lot of
it like you hear these stories like from
the 70s that you saw on like arthur c
clarke or in search or whatever or that
you read like in my readers diet as well
and then you never follow up on it i yes
remember it back then but then in the
ensuing years right like other sites
happen although i have followed up on
someone must share this with the
audience those big-ass [ __ ] triangle
UFOs huh I always thought there was
something to that and I mean the [ __ ]
there the witnesses were good there was
lots of them it's just a strange [ __ ]
reports of gigantic triangle UFOs
there's an aviation historian I forgot
his name off the top of my head but [ __ ]
you know somebody asked me I'll in the
in the comment section I'll answer you
know I'll find it out who he is he he's
been [ __ ] watching the black aviation
world for [ __ ] years this dude's he's
one of the he's a [ __ ] ultra nerd he's
super much super into these [ __ ]
aviation world okay
he said he's about my age in his 50s and
he [ __ ] has been researching the
Chevron shaped UFOs in triangle-shaped
UFOs for a long time and he came up with
a good explanation for that
he said that they were first seen around
80s that in the Reagan era all right and
they've kind of dropped off the radar in
recent times he thought that might've
been a nuclear-powered solid-body
Zeppelin basically to house a
high-powered radar system for the Star
Wars at the Star Wars program the spot
incoming ICBMs over the [ __ ] horizon
a radar that could stay on station for
months at a time out over the ocean that
actually makes sense and that makes
perfect sense because there was a lot of
that I remember that star warship that
was not where's the movie we're talking
about Star Wars the SDI strategic defend
the incoming we're gonna blow up the
rough missiles as they're coming and
because it would have a nuclear reactor
on it kind of like a submarine okay it
would violate a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
treaties we have Soviets it would have
been secret to this day yeah it was just
been a basically electric powered
Zeppelin using nuclear electric
something that was kind of solid body
that housed a big radar and could be big
you know [ __ ] there's several miles
across or a mile across size of a
[ __ ] destroyer you know or a quart of
the submarine really really in mass you
know a big you know one if you just hang
out there over the ocean and move around
you know as needed you know but you know
might have a crew of 10 you know and it
could just stay deployed for a couple
months at a time and that makes sense
oh yeah an airborne radar so you said I
always kind of felt like I'm not saying
that everybody that sees things that are
purported to be UFOs are crazy I'm so
just like a lot of them probably did see
[ __ ] but I think 99.99999 percent of the
time it's more likely that it is some
secret yeah aircraft and the reason why
it's like I said what aliens I don't
think they would come here well I'm
gonna differ on that you know I mean for
now well that's for a different show
yeah probably the reason why
like that would still be seekers because
it violated some kind of treaty well
yeah because our ass would be grass if
somebody found out well I would look bad
they couldn't do anything to us it must
look bad then we were violating treaties
Yeah right so we've gone on long enough
about thoughtography about ted serios
and about various other topics yeah
[Laughter]
cheese cloth up in your all that kind of
stuff they just the bewildering panoply
of topics that we always cover here on
13 o'clock we we like to have some
variety on each of our trade show it's
kind of yeah it's kind of leaning more
toward nc-17 you don't honestly sorry
about that warren hope no children are
listening we should put a little warning
help us out share the channels with
france help us grow youtube's [ __ ] of
[ __ ] us over and the algorithms for
now it's not just us it's everybody but
channels aren't growing like they were
they're trying to make everybody [ __ ]
watch cable news programs cable programs
in them and nobody wants cable YouTube
exists because cable sucks well that's
not gonna work out yeah like I said you
know we have our six seven subscribers
and however many people listen to us on
iTunes I don't we can we can use four
more thousand though yeah so it's good
okay yeah if every single one of you
pass through other people it's like you
know I I realize like not everyone's
gonna be into this stick here I know cuz
I know were annoying [ __ ] sometimes
and we're kind of [ __ ] no but I'm
just saying I you know I'm just I'm just
trying to come from you know a point of
view look like somebody to be like it
with is that so yeah swearing at me cuz
you know how [ __ ] and some people are
about swearing for whatever alright but
anyways if you liked the show like share
subscribe on all your social media it
really does help a lot like I said I'm
trying to get more subscribers
especially since YouTube seems to be
like slowing everybody down yeah they
are yeah you know so whatever if you'd
like to financially support the
show you go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
to a PayPal account if you'd like to
give a one-time donation that would also
be much appreciated
remember these regular episodes here
come out every Tuesday we also 13
o'clock movie retrospectives usually an
older movie that comes out every Friday
and the thirst and o'clock matinee
that's three new movies in the theater
and that comes out every Sunday so check
them out if you haven't already and this
will that will do it for episode 142 we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]